You have a new to you yarn that you'd
like to knit with and where do you start?
Now the ball band may gave you some
information about the suggested needles to
use for hand knitting and what stitches
you might get, but as machine knitters,
this doesn't tell us anything.
This doesn't tell us what tension to
turn on the tension dial of your machine.
Let's spend some time today playing with
a get-acquainted swatch . Now when we're
talking about a get-acquainted swatch,
I used to call this a tension swatch, so
it's just a little swatch that lets you
know how the yarn is going to knit up.
The concept of a get acquainted swatch
was introduced to me by a fellow knitter,
Nancy, who knits a lot.
She does production knitting.
And anytime she gets a new yarn, she casts
on and starts knitting with that yarn in
the stitch pattern that she's hoping to
use, and she'll start way down at the
tightest tension and work all the way up
to the loosest tension, marking as she
goes.
Not to be confused with the gauge swatch,
a gauge swatch is what you knit so that
you can
calculate what your stitches and rows are.
I'm talking about a get-acquainted swatch.
It's just a way for you to play around
with the yarn to see how it's going to
knit on your machine.
What tension that you like, the feel
of as you're knitting this new yarn.
I have this new yarn and I don't know what
to do with it, so I'm going to cast on a
few stitches.
Yeah, maybe 20 stitches or so.
Now in my experience, I know that
this is a worsted weight yarn.
I'm looking at the ball band.
It tells me information that will let me
know that this is probably a bulky or a
mid gauge yarn.
I'll cast on a few stitches
and just start knitting.
Now.
Also, with some experience, I've learned
that you know, this worsted weight yarn is
going to knit somewhere in about the
middle of my tension dial, so I'm probably
not going to knit this heavy, heavy
yarn at attention zero, right?
And tension 10 at the opposite end of
the gauge is probably going to be way too
loose.
I'll start at about the
middle of the tension dial.
So for my tension swatch or my
get-acquainted swatch, I just cast on
maybe about 20 stitches or
so and knit for a little bit.
I started at tension 7, sort of middle
of the range of my tension dial.
I'll knit for an inch or so,
and then mark my tension.
I use eyelets to mark the tension
and then knit a couple more inches.
Now immediately as I'm knitting, I can
tell tension 7 with this yarn is just too
loose for me, so I'm going to crank down
the tension by one full number, put in
some eyelets again, I'll take it
down to 6 and knit for a few inches.
Now that's feeling a lot better.
Just to be on the safe side.
I'm going to crank it down
one more tension to a 5.
Again, marking with eyelets, just so I
have some space in between these areas.
And I can tell as it's coming off the
machine that this might be a little bit
too tight.
I'll just drop this
swatch off the machine.
Now again, I can just feel and
get a feel for what I like.
This is in stockinette.
If I was knitting in a stitch pattern, I
would do it in the stitch pattern as well.
And honestly, with this yarn, if I was
going to knit in tuck , I might knit at
the tension
7.
You just need to play.
We're giving you permission to play with
the yarn and play with your machine.
Now, another thing that a tension
swatch can do for you is show you what's
happening with this yarn.
Maybe the yarn will bias.
Maybe the yarn isn't appropriate
for the knitting machine.
Um, if you're worrying about the yarn
bleeding or shrinking, it's good to play
with this swatch and see what happens.
If you throw this in the machine and it
shrinks down, you'll have an idea of what
tension to knit it at so that you
maintain the feel that you like.
Nancy puts a tag on her, get-acquainted
swatch, and then puts it in with the cone
or the balls, and if she's going to store
the yarn, so that she has something to
reference, she puts as much
detail on that tag as she can.
So she remembers what machine she used,
what tension she use, what she did to this
swatch, and, and the brand name and when
she bought it and all that good stuff.
So put as much detail as you can.
So when you go back to buy this yarn
again, you have the facts and you can get
knitting quickly.
So now that I have this tension swatch,
I'm going to go ahead and knit my gauge
swatch, measure this gauge swatch.
I'll dress it, hang it, do whatever I need
to the proper way for a gauge swatch, and
I'm ready to get knitting.
My garment will have the proper gauge
and it'll feel the way I want it to feel.
So I'll use a Knit it Now pattern.
I'll draft my own pattern.
I'll use software based on my gauge.
I'm not matching anybody else's gauge.
If you struggle with your knitting and
your knitted items don't come out the
right size.
Swatching is not optional.
We have an entire classroom at Knit
it Now on the subject of swatching.
Knititnow.com/SWATCH.
I hope you'll embrace knitting of
getting-acquainted swatch when you try new
yarn.
It'll save you time and also open up a
world of possibilities with the wide range
of yarns that we have available
to use on our knitting machines.
Until next time, thanks for watching.
Happy knitting.